je viens vous parler aujourd'hui des 80
miller que chacun d'entre vous va
consacrer à son travail dans sa vie
quatre-vingt mille heures c'est pas rien
il se trouve même que c'est quelque
chose de tellement conséquent que si
vous faites des compromis sur cette
thématique sur cette activité
eh bien il sera difficile d'espérer être
heureux en général et en tant que
psychologue du travail
le problème que je constate au quotidien
c'est que je côtoie un ensemble de
personnes qui n'ont pas encore 30 ans et
qui chaque matin se lève en se demandant
pourquoi est-ce qu'elles vont investir
autant de temps et autant d'énergie dans
un projet dans lequel elle ne se
réalisent pas c'est presque même
paradoxal pour elle parce que ce métier
l'on choisit donc il ya une forme de
culpabilité
j'ai choisi ce métier je peux pas m'en
plaindre et pourtant je me réveille et
je me demande pourquoi je veux faire
tout ça j'ai l'impression d'être
personnes alors que je fais tout pour
être quelqu'un j'ai l'impression de
passer mon temps à passer à côté de ma
vie alors c'est quelque chose qui n'est
pas forcément banalité et c'est quelque
chose quand même qu'on a tous et auquel
enfin c'est un sujet auquel on a tous
été sensibilisés c'est facile d'en
parler
on a tous été sensibilisés au fait qu'il
est important qu'on trouve un job qui
nous plaisent on a tous été sensibilisés
au fait qu'il faut réaliser ses rêves
on a tous entendu ça et pourtant la
réalité c'est qu'une minorité de
personnes se réalise aujourd'hui dans
son job et une majorité passe son temps
à faire des compromis et a passé à côté
de son potentiel
donc ça veut dire qu'il ya un moment
même si l'on sait qu'on devrait réaliser
nos rêves et bien suffi ce n'est pas
suffisant il ya la réalité qui nous
rattrape
on se retrouve coincé et au final on se
retrouve dans une vie qu'on assume qu'à
moitié
il se trouve que moi j'ai cherché à
suivre ce message là je les ai écoutés a
dit réaliste et rêve et quand j'avais 14
ans et que j'ai dû faire mon premier
stage au collège comme comme tous ici
j'ai choisi d'aller dans un cabinet de
vétérinaire parce que c'était mon rêve
et j'ai fait ce stage c'était
passionnant c'était tellement
passionnant que j' y consacrer toutes
mes vacances scolaires pendant les trois
prochaines années
ce qui fait qu'à 17 ans j'avais cumulé
environ huit mois d'expérience et je
m'épanouisse est totalement dans ce
futur métier de vétérinaire et la
réalité qui m'a rattrapé c'est qu'en
première j'ai eu une certaine difficulté
scolaire et j'ai dû redoubler et j'ai dû
mettre fin à votre guise n'est à mes
projets à mes rêves de vétérinaire à
l'avenir parce que ça demandait de
passer par une prépa très compliqué donc
la réalité m'a rattrapé à ce moment là
et c'est bizarre parce que j'avais 17
ans j'avais l'impression de devoir déjà
faire un compromis dans la vie en ne
pouvant pas choisir le job de mes rêves
et la réalité a fait de moi un
psychologue du travail
c'était pas trop mal au final on reste
toujours un peu bizarre les gens ne
parlent pas trop en guinée mais on est
psychologue dans le travail donc ça va
on n'est qu'à moitié bizarre et en tant
que psychologue du travail ce qui est
quand même intéressant c'est qu'on peut
être amené à étudier pourquoi une
minorité de personnes se réalise à
travers son job alors qu'une majorité
passe à côté de son potentiel et c'est
ce que je fais au quotidien
la première remarque que j'avoue faire
là dessus c'est qu'on se trompe
totalement quand on n'imagine ce qu'est
une personne qui réussit au travail on a
des modèles en tête des personnes qu'on
érige en terme de deux modèles de
réussite professionnelle et il se trouve
qu'on a l'impression qu'elles ont réussi
leur rêve parce que elle avait les
moyens intellectuels
elle avait potentiellement les moyens
financiers elle avait le contexte avec
elles elles ont réussi c'est super mais
moi j'ai pas forcément ça soit parce que
l'intellectuel manger était limité soit
parce que j'ai été limités
économiquement et il ya tout un tas de
choses contextuel qui ont fait que j'ai
pas pu accéder à céret donc bravo bravo
pour elle mais moi je ne suis pas là
alors qu'en fait quand on regarde de
plus près les gens que l'on érigé en
modèle de réussite professionnelle n'ont
pas réalisé leur rêve vraiment mark
zuckerberg n'a jamais rêvé de développer
un réseau social où il y aurait des
millions de personnes dessus je pense
pas non plus que larry page et sergey
brin et rêver durant leur enfance de
développer un moteur de recherche en
ligne
je vous parle pas de steve jobs et des
ordinateurs des tablettes des téléphones
ça fait pas rêver comme projet
professionnel
et pourtant c'est ce qu'ils ont fait et
pourtant on les admire pour ce qu'ils
ont fait
ce qui s'est passé avec ces personnes là
c'est qu'elles n'ont pas poursuivi leurs
rêves
elles ont été confrontés à une réalité
qui ne leur convenait pas et elles ont
mis tout leur talent et toute leur
énergie pour changer cette réalité quand
quand steve jobs a découvert que les
nouvelles technologies pourraient
changer la façon dont on fonctionnait
dans le monde
il a été à berrer par le fait qu'elle
soit adressée à des experts alors que
normalement devrait penser pour
n'importe qui face à cette réalité qui
ne me convenait pas il a utilisé ce
qu'il savait et ce qui le distinguait
des autres
les quelques cours qu'il avait réussi à
suivre à l'université c'était des
courses de 10 étaient des cours de
typographie donc il avait un sens du
design et comme vous le savez il avait
une personnalité particulièrement
déterminés et pointilleuse et finalement
quand on quand on allie ça on a
l'identité d'apple cancer gay briner
larry page devait mener leurs recherches
à stanford dans leur cour de computer
science
il était à berrer par le fait que dans
les recherches en ligne
il tombait sur des pages qui n'avait
rien à voir avec ce qu'il voulait il
savait modélisés à des données
informatiques
ils ont développé leur propre modèle de
recherche pour être plus efficace ils
ont développé google mark zuckerberg
était envieux de voir les fraternités
les confréries harvard et pourtant ils
n'avaient pas vraiment le profil
pourrait accéder se doit ce à quoi ils
étaient bons s'était développée
informatiquement et il s'est un peu
vengé de ces de cette exclusion en
déplaçant la réalité vers reims un
domaine que lui maîtrisait mieux que
n'importe qui et qui pourrait le mettre
au centre les réseaux sociaux alors
quand on regarde pourquoi les gens
réussissent ce n'est que quelques
exemples mais c'est pas qu'ils ont
poursuivi leur rêve c'est qu'ils ont
réussi à dépasser une réalité qui leur
posaient problème en mettant à
contribution leur talent je vous dise à
sa règle pas forcément tous les
problèmes de se réaliser personnellement
parce que ça explique simplement
qu'aujourd'hui on ait des on est une
minorité qui a un talent très fort et
qui réussit à le mettre à contribution
de la société
c'est super mais qu'est ce qu'on fait de
la majorité qu'est ce qu'on fait de la
majorité qui n'a pas un talent fou
naturel et qui pour autant doit trouver
sa place dans
il est bien certes on peut pas tout cet
exceptionnel mais ce qui est certain
c'est qu'on a tous 80 mille heures à
investir et soit on se dit qu'on va
faire ce qu'on peut ou soit on cherche
une autre solution et on cherche à
retourner cette réalité je vous donne un
exemple des outsiders qui a pensé comme
ça en 2002 l'équipe des athletics
d'oakland qui est une équipe de baseball
américaine a est parti de là dans la
ligue américaine avec l'avant dernier
budget autant vous dire que quand on à
l'avant dernier budget de la ligue on
recrute que les joueurs dont personne ne
veut alors espérer gagner un championnat
comme ça c'est pas évident la majorité
des équipes font ces petits budgets se
disent ben on va essayer de trouver des
pépites des potentiels on va s'entraîner
comme des fous on va être motivé
on va jouer l'esprit d'équipé puis au
final si on a une position dans la
moyenne ce sera déjà pas mal avec nos
moyens
billy beane le manager de l'époque
aurait pu faire ce choix là mais il
s'est dit bon quitte à être avec une
réalité qui n'est pas avec moi
autant jouer le jeu jusqu'au bout et si
je peux pas voir les joueurs qui sont
excellents en soit je vais essayer de
regarder autre chose et il a balayé
toutes les statistiques des joueurs qui
restaient en regardant toutes leurs
phases de jeu a le nom leur réussite ont
lancé leur site en réception leur
vitesse de jeu leur puissance leur
explosivité
il a pris toutes ces statistiques il
cherchait des personnes dont personne ne
voulait mais qui pouvait exceller sur
une petite partie du jeu et il a réussi
à en trouver pour chaque partie du jeu
du baseball
il a monté son équipe comme ça il a
développé toute sa stratégie autour de
ça en mettant les joueurs uniquement sur
les phases de jeu sur lequel il était
bon à côté de ça c'était des
catastrophes et c'est pour ça que les
autres équipes ne voulaient pas c'est
pas un conte de fées il se trouve que
cette équipe-là a remporté le
championnat en 2002 et ça s'est
reproduit dans les années suivantes
ils ont pu dépasser cette réalité en
s'appropriant de nouvelles techniques
que personne ne maîtrise à l'époque
donc on peut peut on peut partir
outsider mais quand on arrive à
identifier ce pour quoi on est meilleur
que les autres ce qui nous singularise
et il ya tous un élément qui nous
caractérise à ce niveau là
on est tous différents dans cette salle
il ya forcément quelque chose que vous
faites mieux que n'importe qui ici et
quand on a trouvé ça et qu'on invite
qu'on y investit toute son énergie
on peut créer une différence et cette
différence nous permet de nous réaliser
au travail alors je vais vous donner un
peu de recul aussi sur cette différence
elle vient d'où comment est-ce qu'on
peut l'identifier
cette question les psychologues se la
posent depuis plus de 100 ans le premier
a été francis galton il a étudié
notamment les viols les violonistes à la
fin du 19e siècle pour essayer de
comprendre pourquoi certains violoniste
était exceptionnelle et pourquoi
d'autres étaient justes moyens et donc
il a mené son enquête son observation
est ce qu'il a constaté c'était dans la
famille bach
il y avait 20 violoniste exceptionnel
nous on retiendra que jean-sébastien
mais en fait il avait toute une fratrie
des cousins assez assez excellent donc
ce qu'il a conclu abbès avec ce constat
plus d'autres c'était que le talent
c'était génétique et quand on arrivait à
reprendre le talent familial ça
fonctionnait super bien pour l'anecdote
calton était un cousin de darwin donc à
l'époque ça passait bien de penser comme
ça mais un siècle après quand ericsson a
voulu un peu reproduire cette expérience
à à berlin en étudiant à l'école des
violonistes ce qui faisait qu' il y
avait des élèves exceptionnelles et des
aides soignantes ce qu'il a constaté ces
textes et pas du tout le milieu social
qui avait créé ce talent là parce qu'on
était au 20e siècle et parce qu'il n'y
avait pas besoin d'avoir une famille
violoniste pour être bon en violon est
ce qu'il a constaté c'était que les
meilleurs violonistes avait consacré
plus de dix mille heures en moyenne à
leur pratique alors que les moyens avait
consacré moins de 4000 heures et là la
conclusion ça a été mettez toute votre
activité votre tout votre temps dans une
activité que vous voulez réussir parce
qu'au bout de dix mille heures ça marche
donc persévérer
malcom gladwell a repris sa dans son
livre outlier et on a fait la loi des
dix mille heures et c'est devenu une
lubie s'ils ont pratiquement andy miller
on va devenir géniaux c'était un peu
larnack de la fin du xxème siècle parce
qu'en fait certes les personnes qui
avaient réussi avait dû passer dit
miller pour réussir mais c'est pas parce
qu'on passe est dit miller qu'on
réussissait et si elle avait passé dix
mille heures jusque là c'est parce
qu'elle avait un potentiel pour réussir
dans cette activité
et aujourd'hui pour vous dire on en est
en termes de psychologie du travail ce
qui fait qu'on n'ait plus talentueux que
les autres cellier environ entre 5 et 25
% à l'expérience à ce qu'on va pratiquer
au quotidien et plus on multiplie les
heures et plus on a de probabilité de
réussir sur ce créneau de 20 à 25 % de
réussite et tout le reste c'est du
contexte et surtout les caractéristiques
individuelles alors on l'a entendu en
début de conférence les caractéristiques
individuelles elles vont être lié à quoi
d'une part au raisonnement aux aptitudes
intellectuelles et d'autre part à la
personnalité et ce qui est intéressant
aujourd'hui dans ce qui se joue dans nos
sociétés c'est que la personnalité elle
monte en importance tout simplement
parce que on a accès à l'information on
à l'accès à des technologies qui
compense on va dire un peu de capacités
intellectuelles
par contre interagir avec les autres
travailler en équipe
collaborer développer des idées ça c'est
pas forcément l'intelligence qui le fait
donc à partir de qui vous êtes vous
pouvez trouver un point de singularité
qui vous permet si vous investissez tout
votre temps de vous démarquer des autres
donc pour ceux réalisés à travers son
travail il y à certaines questions à se
poser et c'est celle que j'aimerais que
vous repreniez vous reteniez ce soir
qu'est ce qui dans la réalité vous pose
problème est que vous ne supportez pas
et en quoi votre singularité vous permet
de répondre à ce problème de manière
unique mieux que n'importe qui dans
cette salle
si vous trouvez ça et que vous y
investissent et 80 milliards je peux
vous dire que vous allez vous réaliser
professionnellement
personnellement j'ai pas supporté avoir
à faire un compromis sur ma carrière et
j'ai pas supporter qui est des gens qui
vivent un travail qu'à moitié au
quotidien
c'était la réalité que je ne supportais
pas ce que j'ai fait en devenant
psychologue du travail s'est développé
des solutions d'évaluation aujourd'hui
utilisé par les entreprises et les
cabinets majoritairement pour identifier
le potentiel et les talents individuels
et s'assurer qu'elles soient mis en
oeuvre dans les shops dans les jobs dans
lesquelles il allait recruter les
personnes
voilà donc je vous invite à trouver
cette réalité que vous voulez
transformer à 1 et invite à y investir
aux 80 miller merci